the book which didn't come out for two
years after I first started writing
screenplay was it was a best-seller and
it's one of those odd things it just
wasn't fashionable at the time to make a
scary film for kids but that's kind of
what Walt Disney had done in in you know
all of his movies from you know for
relative ill will be back to the Wicked
Queen in Snow White and Tokyo's best
friend being turned into a donkey you
know so there's certainly a desire for a
mix of you know tones in animated films
I'd met lenny lipton who's you know in
many respects the father of modern 3d
cinema
it's his technology that really uses one
of the chief proponents I've met him 20
years ago I did a 3d rock video for the
viewmaster corporation then they
realized there was no way to actually
show it to anyone it didn't go into
their viewers which I still love but I
met Lenny so I got exposed to 3d from
someone who was developing new new
technology and I was sort of checking in
with him every few years as it developed
it was harder than I thought it would be
quite honestly I I knew I wanted the
real world to feel flattered but I
didn't want to just turn up the 3d in
the other world we actually designed the
world's different that there's actually
more depth to the sets and the other
world core line goes to we crushed the
sets they had very little depth in the
real world it we started shooting in
sort of the safer areas and kept testing
two weeks ahead of what we needed to do
because I checked my DP goes all the way
back to before nightmare made huge
contributions you know for some of the
lead characters something I've always
enjoyed his complete replacement
animation Jack Skellington every
expression it's a different head he's
basically a ping-pong ball with two
holes in her mouth and it was um
sculpting a hundred and fifty different
expressions was not an overwhelming task
but for Coraline we wanted to go a lot
farther make her far more expressive so
for her and a couple of the other lead
characters we
we actually use 2d drawings the sky
Shane prig more one of our three
character designer is also a very good
2d animator he figured out in 2d all the
expressions for her and that became the
guide to produce in the computer which
then printed them out as 3d actual
objects which we then used in this set
so those facial animations were you know
figured out but using 2d animator his
work as a guide but for the rest of the
film the animators don't work it out 2d
first moving puppets posing puppets
that's what they do they perform through
the puppets of the film we have standing
puppets for the lighters you know just
foam rubber they keep falling over we do
blocking tests sometimes we'll do a full
rehearsal and you know there's notes
there's back-and-forth they have their
exposure sheets like we've always had at
the end of the day though they're
launched and they perform they have to
get from this side of the chasm to the
other
you